There are a risk of disintegrating cancer cells,
disintegrated cancer cells going somewhere else in the body and causing problems.
What happens to the cancer cells that are destroyed using a rif machine?
Good question. So, if the rif works,
could you end up a cybertype reaction because only these cancer cells,
and it's causing waste from these cancer cells to affect body?
So, the short answer is this, no, this is not going to happen.
And the reason is that the rif doesn't work,
so there's different ways cells die.
So cells can die from normal programmed cell death called apoptosis.
So apoptosis takes place when a cell actually,
actually the term is blabbed in on itself.
So, the cell kind of inverts on itself and starts breaking in part.
And it has actually recycled.
So, let the cell material inside the cell,
including the cell membrane, what makes it up.
A cell membrane, the phospholipid bilayer is reutilized by the body,
reutilized by other cells.
So, it's actually really a recycling of cell material.
So, what a cell is destroyed even through your T cells and your natural killer cells,
they stimulate what's called an extrinsic from the outside apoptotic reaction.
So, the cell goes through apoptosis.
So, you don't end up with toxins.
The cell doesn't explode and cause toxins to be dispersed
in the extracellular matrix that need to be carried away by the lymph system.
That takes place in a, what's called a pathological death of a cell.
A pathological death of a cell is a process called cell lysis
where the cell membrane does break apart and kind of explode.
And it produces a lot of waste,
which is called endotoxins, waste from within.
And that has to be carried away through your lymphatic system
because it makes a mess in the extracellular matrix.
Matrix, that's the matrix of fluid and waste products between cells.
And then that's carried away through your lymph system.
And then it has to go through detox pathways.
That is a problem when you use the rife for killing single cell organisms.
So, if you're using the rife to kill bacteria,
you can and you will produce endotoxins.
So, you'll produce waste from that bacteria.
Now, it's usually not a problem unless a person has huge issues
with their detoxification pathways.
Unless you're killing a certain type of bacteria
called gram-negative bacteria.
Gram-negative bacteria,
Lyme disease, beryllia, burgodorphia,
is a gram-negative bacteria at each part of the organism.
The gram-negative bacteria, if you kill them both too quickly.
The other thing with gram-negative bacteria is that they have
lipopolysaccharides in their cell membranes.
And those liberate and those can cause an inflammatory reaction
cause what could be known as a herxymaraction.
But to answer the question,
when you're killing cancer cells using the rife,
typically using any other natural approach,
you're not going to cause a herxymaraction.
You're not going to cause endotoxins to be produced.
You're not going to overwhelm the detox pathways.
So, I know that you will do that with chemotherapy.
Chemotherapy kills cancer via lysis and through apoptosis.
So, you can produce endotoxins when you use chemotherapy.
That can be part of why a person feels ill
post chemotherapy.
Of course, the other reason is that chemotherapy
isn't going to be exclusively killing cancer cells.
It will be killing healthy cells too.
It can damage the blood brain barrier,
cross the blood barrier, cause inflammation of the brain,
causing all sorts of things.
So, while chemotherapy can be great to kill cancer,
it causes other ill effects as well.
So...